[Applause]
[Applause]
I repeat government Robin hereby
formally tender my resignation as the
president of the republic of broadway
with immediate effect
[Applause]
teacher anti-colonial revolutionary to
elected Prime Minister then a ruthless
dictator the evolution of Robert Mugabe
from a leader who was steering Zimbabwe
to a bright economic future to a despot
who bled his country dry
and disposed of opponents who dared
stand in his way
but Mugabe was able to use the outcry
from Britain and elsewhere to his
advantage and present himself as a hero
who stood up to imperialism we have
fought for our land we have fought for
our sovereignty small as we are we have
one now independence and we are prepared
to shed our blood in sustenance and
maintenance and protection of that
independence and that's how he first
came to international attention leading
a guerrilla movement to overthrow
Rhodesia is white government the
country's Prime Minister Ian Smith had
tried to resist majority rule by
declaring unilateral independence from
Britain in 1965 only four percent of the
country's population was white having
previously been jailed Mugabe led a
campaign of violent resistance from
exile in Mozambique the bloody bush war
throughout the 1970s eventually led to a
negotiated settlement at lancaster house
britain's Foreign Secretary Lord
Carrington brokered a deal which saw
Mugabe and rival revolutionary joshua
como temporarily united british
authorities oversaw the democratic
elections which followed and Robert
Mugabe triumphed he was congratulated by
Prince Charles as majority rule finally
came to the new Zimbabwe
finally a formal handover from Britain
and a new nation was born initially the
country prospered white settlers and
their descendants were encouraged to
stay and Zimbabwe was held up as an
example of what could be achieved at a
time when South Africa's white rulers
still clung to apartheid Margaret
Thatcher came to her Ari full of praise
the GAVI had sacked his one-time partner
Joshua Como and his Zabu party was
merged with Mugabe za knew two forms an
OPM Mugabe was consolidating his power
[Music]
but 12 years after independence and with
British colonial heritage still
celebrated his in Bob way was a country
which seemed forward-looking and at
peace with itself
yeah I'll try 90 Beckett the former
Prime Minister's stayed on in the
country while cautioning against Mugabe
--zz Marxist policies if we can change
from a government which believes in
communism to one that believes in the
free enterprise system
in we find we have a wonderful country
but with white farmers still owning the
bulk of the land veterans of the war and
the unemployed grew impatient a dispute
with Britain over compensation for land
redistribution saw farmers intimidated
beaten or even murdered the Gabby's
government allowed it to happen
then facilitated it and encouraged it
ignoring court rulings that it was
illegal how can you surrender something
willingly you've lived on for 60 years
we shall have to sell all the mulatto I
suppose to get our tongue get our money
back and this sort of thing and jumpers
and what-have-you will try and sell all
this before we go and all out the back
iron man and capital and we went putting
a wheat crop and then the comrades the
very best of British luck decades of
agricultural experience departed
voluntarily or forcibly the consequence
was that a country which was once
regarded as the breadbasket of Africa
began to starve harvests shrank shelves
were empty and rampant inflation meant
currency became virtually worthless
through it all Mugabi who took on the
title of president blamed others for the
problems what we reject is the
persistence of vestigial attitudes from
the radition yesteryears attitudes of a
must race master color master owner and
master employer the commonwealth
suspended Zimbabwe's membership Mugabe
opted to quit the organization
international sanctions were imposed
Mugabe remained defiant the Western
countries in particular the United
States and the European Union who
imposed illegal sanctions against
Zimbabwe have to our surprise and that
of Sadek and the rest of Africa refused
to remove those sanctions if they will
not assist the inclusive government in
rehabilitating our air economy could
they please please stop their filthy
clandestine divisive antics
a country rich in natural resources
should have been a beacon for Africa
instead life expectancy rates plummeted
the average Zimbabwean would be dead
before their 40th birthday while Mugabe
was heading for his 90s hours two of his
country's cricketers took to the field
wearing black armbands to protest what
they called the death of democracy they
later went into exile but still Mugabe
supporters lauded him and time and time
again he claimed success in elections
despite allegations of corruption and
manipulation when opposition leader
Morgan Tsvangirai threatened an upset of
the polls he was badly beaten by thugs
supporters of his movement for
Democratic Change saw their homes
demolished under the guise of
redevelopment perhaps out of conviction
maybe to deflect attention away from
other problems President Mugabe became
an outspoken critic of homosexuality
remain human beings if they do worse
than things on several occasions Peter
Tatchell and other gay activists
attempted to make what they called
citizens arrests accusing Mugabe of
torture and the killing of political
opponents under Section 1 through 4 of
the Criminal Justice Act 1988 by 2008
smih gobby was forced to share power
organs finder I became prime minister
but despite his advancing years Mugabe
was showing no inclination to step down
as president at this age I still can go
some distance kadai and in the 2013
elections he regained undisputed power
in a disputed election
by now the sharp Western suits brought
in exchange for something more colorful
that his side his second wife Grace
Gucci grace as she was dubbed because of
her expensive shopping trips she's had
an affair with Mugabe while she was a
secretary and Boren children but after
the death of his first wife they were
married and her own political ambition
grew earlier this year she was accused
of attacking a model during a trip to
South Africa but was allowed to return
home without being prosecuted
neighboring leaders like Jacob Zuma
maintained their high regard for Robert
Mugabe despite international criticism
he was still a hero from the old
struggle for black majority rule
increasingly he took comfort in his
relationships with others who were also
vilified by the West you have senses but
age was catching up with him he often
seemed frail and as he weakened
opposition to him became emboldened
rival MPs heckled a State of the Nation
Address overall economic performance to
date indicates modest growth
[Applause]
culture mining in the sectors of
agriculture mining tourism construction
and in the past week the army joined
that opposition intervening but not they
insisted seizing power they were
ensuring that Emerson managua a former
ally Mugabe Sachs would be his successor
rather than his wife Grace it led to
demonstrations and celebrations that
many Zimbabweans thought they would
never see
[Applause]
[Applause]
Shanno PF is a party of traditions but
in a rambling address to the nation
alongside army officers his much
expected resignation did not come I as
the president of Zimbabwe and as their
commander in chief do acknowledge the
issues they have drawn my attention to
the operation I have alluded to did not
amount to a threat to a well cherished
constitutional order nor was it a
challenge to my authority as head of
state and government but just two days
later a u-turn caused by the threat of
impeachment this from the Speaker of
Parliament in terms of 1696 subsection 1
of the Constitution of Zimbabwe hereby
formally tender my resignation as the
president of the Republic of his bubblin
with immediate effect
[Applause]
in the streets they celebrated the end
of the regime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in a rare interview with Sky News in
2004 Mugabe said he was merely a public
servant I'm a man of the people actually
born peasant family and I've a peasant
background and I know what it is you
know to work with people to hear them
talk to allow them to you know play a
part in in your life and this this is I
think what is carrying me to this day
and although I sit here as president I
know that the that post I owe to the
people
a man who spoke of his admiration for
Britain's royal family will no longer
enjoy the regal lifestyle that came with
his office the British government had
previously stripped him of an honorary
knighthood he received from the Queen
now his own people have taken away a job
he thought he had for life